[Music]
man you can catch us on the bullet Kevin
podcast we outside bye
you have a fake ID
I appreciate y'all coming through man uh
41 is in the building I'm gonna let you
introduce you guys itself Kyle Jen is
here Mark krldg man you know y'all sorry
for us forever this is Jen Carter you
were we got Tata with us we not head off
for me he gonna be here soon yeah uh
well welcome to La guys how's that have
you guys smoked a lot of good California
drugs since you've been here we just got
here oh you just got here but trust me
right after this interview I'm on a yeah
uh do you guys want to get high during
the interview yeah
wow we have a lighter
oh as long as you guys aren't 18.
here [__] all that put that [__] wait
let me see that oh okay I got this [__]
for you
oh what's this it's that big owls baby
[__] yeah no I think this is uh this is
what we're gonna smoke though we're
gonna blow your face off pause
whoa so this is the Gramercy
I think this is oh my wait wait I don't
know I already knew from like the
packaging like it's fake this is serious
this is Mega Series
yeah oh my God
oh he's already oh he's getting to it
it's called lemon Zonkers
just smoke it bro not a lemon is better
though shout out to Gramercy man
some good [__] we'll have a nice Stone
interview
what's in this though uh that is uh it
is [__] gyoza Lemon Cherry gelato
sugar as well so you got some uh just
take it to the face it tastes like sugar
yeah it's good yeah Welcome to
California that is good you know the
crazy thing about New York though is you
guys are kind of trying to be Cali now
with the weed except for you guys are
way more unregulated no you guys are
like the Wild Wild West for real with
the weed [__] now I ain't got a lot of
Wee we got a different angle like this
[__] is cool
I don't know if he's tweaking with this
gangster get that [__] out of here
[Music]
get over the city that's big out
straight from Northern California
all the weed fields are not Cali got
gray weed oh yeah
you guys are just getting packs from us
all that [__] in New York is coming from
here
you just got a guy who got a guy and the
[__] gets put in the mail or someone
drives that's the [__] yeah yeah so this
is the thing about New York City now
right you guys can now go to like a
smoke shop and buy shrooms yo
oh my God would you like to eat shrooms
bro let me says it's like go try that
one the best shot I ever had bro
[Music]
you trying to shroom before the
freestyle is the real question yeah you
can do it yeah he said no no we're not
sure no okay it says no man it's okay
they can save it though everybody should
take it it's a healthy no no you
remember the last time the last time you
told everybody to take it's a micro dose
a little bit of you
yo I'll be taking like sticks
drop the tops go phone this is my [__]
so
um so you guys are from uh Brooklyn
right yeah
bad side are you from bedside
well you guys know about MLP yeah we
were just talking about that sir Posse
my favorite rap groups ever
Brownsville home of the brave putting
work in the street like a slave what you
know about that like one of my favorite
rap groups ever oh [__]
is Brownsville still because they'll
there was a double XL article when I was
a little kid and they interviewed MLP
and I remember they were talking about
how they would like they were just
saying how crazy Brownsville was I
always just assumed Browns was like the
craziest place on Earth is it still that
bad oh I mean it's probably worse yeah
the gentrification hasn't hit
Brownsville yet I mean they trying right
but it's not doing nothing
because the danger the crime is scaring
the white people away yeah
and the hipsters
well ladies who don't shave their
armpits all the types of shoes
independent coffee shops
never go to a Starbucks you got to
support the Indies uh how long have you
guys been rapping
um I mean I've been rapping my whole
life but
I just started taking her [__]
when I was seven for me okay seven so
tasted seven you were rapping when you
were six months old I mean obviously I
could even talk when I'm six months you
said your whole life sir bro same says
seven seven see the rappers you were
seven yeah I've been Baptist I was a kid
but I just started taking it seriously
so two years ago two years ago what was
there like a catalyst for you that like
made you take it serious
should go viral or not like a life hit
me like I graduated high school and I
realized I had to do this all my life
yeah I had to do it my parents wanted me
to go to college but I didn't want to do
it actually I wanted to find my own path
and my passion was music so I chose my
passion I still what about you how long
you been rapping uh
I'm gonna rap for like two years now
you started two years ago yeah I started
robbing two years ago Jesus but um music
like it's been involved like I played
instruments before I started rapping
like I've been in a band before I saw
your dad's like a music teacher yeah you
know what's crazy he was yeah yeah like
was he like the music teacher at the at
the school like you know no no he was
not specifically for my school but you
know he had an interest in music so I
guess it's a genetic thing like even
before the rapping I just love music
what instruments you play I played
trumpet piano
um I tried to do guitar and drums
have you decided like have you busted
out any of the instruments for any
production yet nah but recently I've
been thinking about it it'd be kind of
hard yeah
yeah I will learn trumpet again Trump
would be I was good at it yeah that was
great it was the best of my class so
were you like because you know I think
when you're like really good at
instruments can't you travel and like do
like shows and [__] like yeah yeah we
started doing shows like we had an
independent group in my school that I
went to we started doing shows but it
was mainly just like you know in the
city We Were Young couldn't really go
that's fine
foreign
during the pandemic
that's [__] wild
we was like we was in a crib I was going
through a lot like a lot for me it was
just a lot of time on our hands and
stuff you know
and you guys did you guys graduate high
school during the pandemic yeah like I
have a problem my graduation was on a
football field like this [__] I feel
like the pandemic was like six months
ago but like it's like it's just crazy
to think like I feel like we were still
in a pandemic I don't know how to
explain it that should change everybody
you think like uh had the pandemic not
happen you guys wouldn't have like
focused in on the music maybe I ended up
doing something else that's a good
question me personally
I know I probably wouldn't be rapping I
don't know the pandemic nah it just
striked a lot
it was good for me I mean I don't know
man I caught covered three times but I
did call kova too
you did you yeah just once did you guys
get the jab
good job what's the job [__] vaccine
oh
what the job uh yeah
which one do I gotta just get so I can
go to places yeah they like forced us to
do it and I started giving a hundred
dollars
I caught him worse like what yeah
I quote covert again no so what the [__]
was the purpose of the job
I don't know I don't know we won't dive
into that because we want to make sure
this YouTube video stays up
um yo it's crazy because like I feel
like you know the drill scene and I mean
now that's really New York sound like
when we think about like the hot [__]
out of New York is really the drill [__]
but like um Brooklyn in particular
I feel like right around like 2018 2019
is like really one [__] like
really popped off like pop smoke Fabio
all that [__] little TJ yeah for you
guys
um well you guys always like big drill
fans
could you go I mean that's the
environment for me right that's over
here I go outside out here Joe it's like
you love him more when you was around it
so it's like when Pop smoke came out
like you know you had people from kanazi
like I went to school in Canarsie I
actually went to a casino yeah so we
hung out with a Dusty volcano there yeah
so it's like the love like that he had
to the hood it just makes you it makes
them like they caught the floss yeah the
floors on point like op over there shout
out to them got some good food over
there yeah it felt like it was like it
was cool you know some parts man you
have you guys ever been to the part of
Brooklyn
where they got the uh it's like the
Hasidic Jewish community
Eastern Parkway I don't know bro
I went over there with uh there's a lot
of Jewish communities no it's the
Hasidic Jewish community so like they
have like their own police force and
they have their own ambulances and [__]
it's [__] lit bro Houston right yeah
so like if you got stabbed over there
and the ambulance was there they'd be
like nah word that's so crazy
they're specific like because they have
their own like you know New York's a
wild Place bro so much culture it's
amazing I love it there yeah
when you guys go to La though or other
places do you realize like my life would
be a lot less stressful if I got the
[__] out of this place yo this is why we
like me personally I like getting out of
New York like it's such a it's a noise
it's like New York is reality you gotta
get on the subway bro it's just a lot of
nuggets every day you're rubbing
shoulders with people you don't know oh
no no we better start taking us open I
promise you no but you gotta walk down
the [__] Street every like not doing
it that's how you put yourself
in New York but that's why I like other
places because it's like I get to walk
like um like I get to take a nice walk
and just like get it leave your front
yard get in your car get some [__]
food now I'll probably do that anyway
but New York yeah it's definitely New
York like I ain't gonna lie you're not
even gonna see me in New York like I'm
always on a v
[__] don't know my next move like you
probably know how to move in New York
bro there is like I do feel like um
there's a lot of like negative
connotations with drill music like we
think of like a lot of the violences
come from some of the beefs which
obviously derives mostly from the
streets not necessarily the music I do
feel like you guys are moving with a lot
more of like a positive energy we're
trying to change the image yeah that's
what we've been from a lot of people
just if you were drugs from
some negative [__] that's [__] up hip
hop but no bro it's not that it's just a
style of music right it's just a style
of rapping it's a style of Beats style
of music and everybody's on the drill
[__] now I just think of like running a
little yeah here you go
um would you guys say you guys like are
making a conscious effort to kind of
change the narrative and just kind of do
it in your own way where it's not
necessarily so
revolving around the drama you know what
I mean I feel like that's why
people straight to us because it's like
we don't like tend to go towards the
distance like you know like all the bad
things about drill like we just have our
own sound to it and that's what people
like you know I'm trying to say it's
like we're different we're not trying to
do what everybody else is doing
everybody else they rely on addition
because controversy brings views yeah I
feel like you guys are just relying on
good music real artists like we really
make real music rather Express the
talent than the politics bro
that's super dope uh why is your guy not
here you're the third person why is he
not here where's he at
man
he's not here I mean not he was coming
but like I'm just keep it above for me
he was coming and then the plane turned
around Jesus so they put him on a new
plane and then turned around again
um
probably was like yeah
I turned around twice
he tried to get it twice so it's like so
would you guys kind of consider yourself
obviously you guys put music out
together as a group you guys are a
collective right but you guys are also
solo artists
um it kind of it's a mutang type Vibes
some I kind of like how Griselda is you
know yeah
um what are some of the rap groups that
y'all can like tell me you grew up
listening to that kind of influence what
y'all which are because we kind of like
the group era in music has been over for
a long time we kind of stopped having
that yeah the last group I remember was
like Migos it's like Migos like race
trimmer it's like very few groups that's
where like I was growing up everybody
was in a [__] group it was like
millions of groups Mobb Deep gang star
MLP [__] tracker
Destiny's Child
there's a new group on your guys's label
flow right Chris well Chris where's
Chris yeah yeah Flo's a group right
someone tried to tell me that's like the
first thing that's I mean we haven't had
something like that in a while since
like
and they have a new song with Missy
Elliott
yeah a shot of them
anybody um
that you guys are aspiring to work with
just selling some fan [__] that out it
could be New York be outside of New York
anybody you guys want to [__] put
some fan [__] like yeah who's like who's
your who's your favorite rapper ever all
right my favorite rapper
ever I don't know like I got a lot of
favorite rappers there's only three of
them all right
um I Love Lil Durk late I listen to a
lot of little dirt for me uh that makes
sense Michael Jackson here's the like I
grew up listening to Michael Jackson I
feel like I got my totally not a rapper
Michael Jackson yeah not even just his
music just everything about it for me it
was motivational if you're a little old
though not even if I'm mad young man I'm
saying for him
uh
who else Michael Jackson and uh
uh I don't know
you're not my favorite rapper but I feel
like Drake is the best rapper I'm not my
favorite I respect you I respect that
opinion yeah what about you go oh I got
a lot of favorite rappers too over the
top of my head
um Nicki Minaj shout out to Nikki uh
younger man shout out to younger man
um my last one
uh I would tie it
with a little baby and little dirt
no baby and no dark I like little baby
too I think a little baby I feel like
they sounds compliment each other you
like the joint joint Outlet yeah it's a
little slapped on they're like they're
different but when they come together
it's amazing I agree like they're both
good on their own too who's better I say
a little dirt you think Dirk is a bad
leopard and little baby I like dirt
better okay I feel like Dirk make better
music really that's what my opinion for
a little baby yeah bro like who's a
better at rapping who's better all right
rapping rapping skill Wise It's a little
baby yeah okay
I respect you all about making a good
song
hang it as it is it is you know what you
know what little baby got a little dirt
don't got what hits
like actually yeah tell me one hit like
a real hit I'm not talking about
screaming I'm not talking about in the
streets in the club on tomorrow you got
in the car
and the radio was on and I'm not talking
about laugh now cry later I was just yo
what about say that yo what the [__]
that is a Drake song I was about to say
I saw good Drake I heard that shirt
because you get to have a surreal he is
whose song was that tell me the little
Dirk song that has been an actual hit it
doesn't exist
s
I'm talking about like top 10 on
billboard by himself
a little baby got 15 of those yeah
little Dirk was up and then he went down
and then he came up quick you know what
I love about Derek though it's his story
because he's been he's like you know
like he's he's evolved so much in front
of our eyes
I think it'll separate him you know I
was crazy
it's crazy that I'm right yeah
she was like bro's about to say laugh
now ah
that's it you want to hit this you guys
know you guys gotta raps though let's
put that up
um I'm Gucci bro I go for it yo what's
good man we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our good Folks at my
bookie that's right man NBA season is uh
winding down playoffs are going down so
many ways you can get money you could
bet on who you think's gonna win the
finals you can get your prop bets per
game uh we are finally down to the final
eight right now uh my son's ain't
looking good at the time of recording
not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're going to get that deposit
bonus that deposit bonus is craziest the
sign up bonus you get and uh not only
are basketball football which is
starting to creep up on us baseball's
back MLB baseball man all season long
you get this money plus they got the
online casino if you're into craps
Blackjack roulette [__] slot machines
whatever it is go to mybookie.ag right
now use that promo code bootleg and get
that free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg Kev right now you're gonna get
half off half off half off kingpom.com
tobacco free
natural
raps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is
this is a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah
wrapped around some premium can I buy
shout out to uh King pump go follow one
more time kingpong.com promo code
bootleg Kev say 50 off let's get back to
the interview uh talk about just like in
your opinion do you feel like
um both you guys are 20 both of you
fairly new to taking this [__] serious
we always hear about like negative
aspects of the music industry have you
guys experience anything you don't like
about
being in the music industry any fake
[__] you've encountered anything that's
just a lot of fiction oh my God I feel
like
industry's mad the industries I was
about to say the industry itself is fake
I don't know it's like a game to it it's
a game you gotta play the game it's like
it does it is you ought to play with the
win
or you're just not gonna play by the
rules okay that's why I tell people I'm
like man you gotta kind of just give in
a little play the game and then there's
people say like yo we gotta get up we
gotta do something we got to work and
then you never hear from them yeah uh
what is the best chopped cheese in
Brooklyn
oh no I don't stop using cheese I'm
really more of a big [__] cheese type
of nugget okay gangster I had chopped
trees a few times in your life no no I'm
alive I'm so like like three two years
ago you're driving back to back I just
know the hoods not to get it from
Bushwick oh yeah don't go to Bushwick
for your chopped cheese
gentrified I don't know what it is it's
just wrong that's exactly what it is
yeah
don't do it don't go to Williamsburg for
a chopped cheeseburger
yeah Williamsburg is like I don't even
know what it is I don't think
Williamsburg knows how to make anything
no they have they probably got a bunch
of organic [__] and and again let's
get back to the independent coffee shops
I had coffee one time
nah gangster I had coffee one time like
one time
but coffee is not good like it doesn't
taste
you've never had coffee in your life
gangster
I had to force myself to drink it you
had coffee once in your life yeah to
stay up
and it's it kept me out guys
yeah I never been to Starbucks oh yeah
I've been to Starbucks and I picked out
a bagel now
cream cheese
that shit's crazy to me he never had I
use other things to like boost my energy
it's not cocaine right good that's not
good I have a cocaine we don't do no
cool kids that's good yo what do you use
to boost your energy you take like a
five hour shot
yeah I guess we could call it that what
about you
no coffee that's [__] wild to me I
drink coffee every [__] day of my
it's I I will I would be able to stay up
or just I don't know yeah maybe I just
gotta get up and have a black coffee
black I like it black oh my goodness
there's a difference between black and
white gold so white coffee
okay so let me tell you right so all
coffee is originally black
and then it becomes Williamsburg
gentrified I'll see what you said they
gentrify the black coffee with some
caramel maybe some heavy cream maybe
some half and half maybe some almond
milk I like coffee
I said dirt right beans
whoa
I don't see the hype it's nasty it just
keeps it just gets the job done have you
guys ever had a caramel macchiato
I don't even like caramel frappes from
McDonald's
the mocha [__] is yeah you got it's a
vanilla latte there's egg yes vanilla
latte oh man [__] McDonald's they got
great coffee I mean I'm not great
everything at McDonald's for being
honest McDonald's is fire I just like
putting it off you guys like McDonald's
every time I'll be like let's go to
McDonald's
I agree I agree but we just can't
everyone acts like McDonald's isn't good
it's bad it's not good for you but it's
[__] amazing I should have tasted you
no good I don't know what it is you get
a [__] cheeseburger and you stuff it
with fries with there was there he
washed it down with that
signature only McDonald's Coke because
it doesn't taste do you believe me
telling us like we can't relate I ain't
gonna lie and guess what the McDonald's
Sprite that's the wacky Sprite it's the
only Sprite that tastes like that that's
scary it tastes like it's McDonald's
Sprite TV status I don't know TV static
is crazy like it charges my arteries
right yeah it's like what about the
orange High Sea from McDonald's Orange I
see it's shit's fire I like the food
like after 12 everything closed yeah we
eat a lot though so that's like the
fourth meal
what's your guys's favorite cuisine
every day every morning I don't know why
that's the first bill but because it's
because we wake up late too so it's like
the perfect time so Shake Shack is fire
you get those cheese fries like yeah and
they got wool ass burger outfit for me
you eat that [__] in three bites they
got the [__] milkshakes they got the
seasons
you guys got dogs you can get a dog a
treat yo didn't I say all right yo I
told him you're not gonna Jack a dog
oh
yo like
I'm like yo bro we're my mother I used
to be going to school for me coming home
from basketball practice type shifting
me I'm going home to my crib I see
something in the bushes like I'm like
what's that straight cats oh I'm still
walking this [__] for me I go past this
[__] I turn around and said scratching
my leggings I'm running my legacy are
you sure it wasn't gonna hold like it's
bleeding and that should happen like
three times you are [__] unlucky
Bros
they're out the way usually I don't know
he sure wasn't a rat [__]
yo the size of cats Raj is like the old
thing I might be scared of like juice
how do you live where you live they're
everywhere like I see a ride [__]
there are white people that have those
yeah but for me would you ever have a
right now no no no no no no you want a
cat yeah how do you deal with the rats
in New York they're [__] it's like
wild it's pretty crazy uh it is crazy
but like we don't walk through more so
we don't gotta deal with that no more
you're getting rolled around
we got money we never want to feed bro
come on now you got somebody carrying
you around hey you know who I just by
the way shout out to Lola Brooke I just
had her booked at my club in Scottsdale
and um
she had a guy carrying her around she
always goes every time every time I
should always get in a piggyback you
know what I think she's so small it's
like I did not understand how small when
I seen her again and it happened again I
was like oh yeah this is a routine yeah
I didn't understand how small Overbrook
was and I met her and I was like she
gotta get a bottle and places though
like for me it makes sense no for sure
she yeah shout out to Lola Brook she's
killing it uh for you what's it like
being uh
a female doing what you do
I mean there's a lot of answers to that
question there's a lot of questions give
me a few me personally
um since me being the only female in the
group I try to you know that's why
probably the females like me so much
because like you know they try to like I
try to straight towards them like I'm
trying to be the voice for them out of
the group right I'm trying to be like
dip on some different [__] like you know
like the negative Vibes of the Jewish
I've only been I don't even entertain us
I'm focusing on my music right and you
know I'm trying to be big like it's not
a lot of females like me doing what I'm
doing for sure trying to say so
really trying to stay on my own you know
my own path focus on now I gotta ask are
you lesbian
shout out to you shout out to me I was
gonna ask like you mentioned young MMA
is one of your favorite like raps yeah
like like do you feel like kind of like
she kind of like like you got to see
somebody kind of similar to you from
where you're from dude because I was
young at the time she was blowing up and
it's just like I like the music at the
same time she could rap her ass off how
he is that's probably why I tried to
straight towards the the lyrical [__]
when I rap to her and um Nicki Minaj the
way they rap is like when I'm listening
to these songs I say oh like I want
people to have that reaction to my music
yeah rap some Legends on their own [__]
young MMA specifically though she for me
she had a crazy heads for sure and she's
like she I still think she slept online
and it's really because he just really
don't feel me
I think she ever did a major deal I
think she was always kind of into she
was independental yeah
she was independent like she got her own
thing on that's that's that's what's
inspiring me though yeah I don't really
send me shout out to Young and me she a
legend she got to get flowers more for
sure oh yeah yeah
um what do you guys got coming out I
know you guys got a new song but what's
what's on the way are we doing like
everybody doing the solo [__] to just
give me the rundown what's on the way
well I knew the phone coming every week
for me we just dropped the compilation
you see not 41 [__]
yeah we just dropped that [__] it was
like like the album basically put all
our songs together in one place for me I
was not after that we added a new songs
of our compilation every single week you
guys are adding on to it yeah oh that's
new I mean and then for me
the album won't drop
you guys are gonna get a [__] plaque
off of that for sure that's a that's a
new hack no it is like we're gonna keep
adding new songs to the album until it
goes [__] real smart it sounds like
some [__] French Montana would do
French Montana he's really good at you
know the hacks all right yeah he put He
put [__] what's that song you have
with Kodak Black
[__] I love that song lockjaw oh that's
not Vlogs oh that [__] was like four
years old and it ended up on his new
album I'm like this [__] is and I was in
Florida when this came out I'll show
this vlogged oh for sure that's crazy I
don't know what you're talking about
jobs dude you guys [__] with Kodak
listen to Kodak yeah it's great yeah it
is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick maybe you just need a little
pep in your step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it promise you that all
right baluchu also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the Bluetooth come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm gonna be hanging out at hard Dean
today
that's right put the flyer up Lorac
I'll be at hardean um hanging out all
day today uh the craziest most just
luxurious illest dispensary in the world
located right in Los Vegas Nevada now
Hardy in Las Vegas they are our family
they sponsor the podcast I love those
guys dearly and when I say that it is
the best place I've ever walked into to
buy premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what y'all need to
do is go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas follow him on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating with smells amazing
so look make sure you go to hardine uh
if you're in Vegas get in that Uber get
in that cab as soon as you touch down
say take me to hardine the taxi drivers
the Ubi drivers they know exactly where
it is because it's the hottest spot in
Vegas they go take you straight there
you're gonna tell them I sent you
they're gonna get you situated real
nicely all right Harding underscore Las
Vegas go show them some love go to
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs had Odd Socks
baby they've been [__] with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butthead socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawskis bruh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bro what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview
um all right so any features on the
compilation
surprise
it's a surprise you got away for the
album
oh on a compilation I'm gonna say isn't
it out oh
but yeah but it's like the compilation
is just like it's just our songs like
mainly yeah how did you guys meet
yeah just the whole crew like how'd
everybody come together to be like hey
this is this is fire let's do this
together
really like childhood memories mutual
friends as well like Tata we met Tata
through deep building D builds is
another one of the 401 members that come
together for me so chaos and D builds
they knew each other we all just really
got to know each other
um like I said during the pandemic too
that's when we got happy you guys almost
linked up in the pandemic I mean we knew
each other before that but we got closer
during the pandemic because you know we
came together with the music [__] [__]
yeah you guys missed high school at all
so because when you when you graduated
you have to graduate like virtually yeah
yeah
[__] me up well [__] we shout out for
getting your diplomas man oh yeah yeah
come on man finish the high school oh
yeah that's a big Flex a lot of people
yeah you know my mom took me out I'm
chasing this rap [__] you know I don't
know if I'm gonna get it you know a lot
of people don't even get there I love
them well congrats to y'all for that
that's big what do you miss most about
high school just the homies like not
having I mean I miss [__] no
responsibility I was just about to say
that less responsibilities bro okay
yeah I learned a lot of lessons the fact
like I don't know how to explain it I
didn't learn them in high school but I
learned them after high school right
like in high school you're dead like
forced to be around people
so it's like it's easier to like meet
people make friends when you're really
on your own yeah like you gotta learn
how to maneuver again like with
different people and all of that what
was y'all's favorite subject
what were you good at what was like no
matter what you can a in that [__] you
know what I mean [__] um
vocabulary
I always had an gym I mean that's yeah
writing everybody you ain't getting that
[__] hand Jim what are you doing I
actually enjoyed writing like I enjoyed
writing classes I don't like reading
about like right the the writing aspect
of it you know like analog about like
all that [__] not on not on math no math
I hate my It's My Worship I hate it half
is just like useless
he's like oh that's what I was learning
in high school
you know what is useless
like algebra and like [__]
trigonometry you know the basics is
various I used to be good at math but
all the extras yeah like when am I going
to do trigonometry bro in life why don't
you give me a [__] class on how to do
my taxes instead thank you for these
[__] oh yeah
but I used to be good at math I felt
like when I started going downhill with
math was seventh grade I went to Africa
for a month oh that sounds sick and I
came back lost so I I don't know it was
just hard during the school year you
went to Africa in the middle of school
yeah I went to Africa my mom took me
so you went back to like visit family
and I don't know why they chose the
middle of the school yeah yeah something
like you gotta catch up on the [__]
homework yeah I had to do all of that
and it just got confused because we
missed like four weeks so it's like
Magcon because you know you start
missing like a certain amount of days
and a [__] truing officer would be
coming to your crib like hey what's up
with these kids are they good yeah yeah
that's true that's crazy uh all right
well look the compilations out you guys
are gonna keep adding new songs
you good you high
um
before you guys leave we're gonna try
coffee
we're gonna do this on camera too
oh no
can I bet [__] it what a cool if you go
follow them online
um and of course uh shout out to ig's
[Music]
Fremont Ohio for me is it gone yeah bro
they deleted my [__] they violated it
really can you sleep bro what'd you do
what'd you post bro I don't even know
now it wasn't even me I ain't a lot it
was an Ops I told they fans to spend my
[__]
the real Jen Carter two ends
yeah two ones the real John Carter all
right what's your what's your new one
with not as many followers
real call Rich for me
hey shout out to you for going by the
governments too huh I mean it's not
really the government what's it is your
first name Kyle in real life yeah by the
way
it's not a bad like uh frat bro name
Kyle what's that
what's up I mean oh it wasn't call me
Kylie they used to call me some other
Chicago I was like my middle name but I
started jacking I was my first name to
tell you [__] at least you're not a
Chadwick oh I don't know
that's crazy
yo you just killed the world
Chad yeah should he be crazy
[Music]
at your son you have kids
well um I'm Jennifer are you guys both
childless yes let's keep it that way
kids
lots of drugs whoa of the decent sort
marijuana and shrooms marijuana
positivity yeah
hookah is way worse for you what are we
talking about
using the same tip because they're
[__] cheap and Dusty that like get
your own [__] tip I don't even know
you [__]
what the [__]
spend the three dollars get your own
[__] tip anyway oh appreciate y'all
bro [__] with you